[Musica]
sono mesi che mettono era tutti ragazzi
e benvenute questo nuovo video sono
fatti j m ci siamo su henry section
primi ragazzi un gioco simpaticissimo
tipo tipo che mario logli la musica che
si strada non oso immaginare il gioco
vediamo era prevista sto qualsiasi che
ovviamente non funziona un cazzo allora
che cosa scrivono premi il tasto
qualsiasi carminativo che dobbiamo
iniziare start già all trovato
difficoltà nel premere stato quindi
partiamo da dio regala donato un melone
di ieri è stato rubato da porta dentro
al fatti più fatta le trote alla mia
bisogna recuperare un melone fantastico
perché è una vasca mi è caduta in testa
c'è la prima [ __ ] schermata non
riesco già a farla ma che cazzo ma mi
state prendendo per il culo non
seriamente rega ma che cazzo nel car
no ma [ __ ] ok perfetto va fatta già
stato difficile fare questo cioè della
prima schermata
ma che cazzo andiamo nell'altro mondo
perché nor indicato quello di prima ti
prego di minino ok meno male ma ciò che
l'uccellino cosa ci fai qua tra l'altro
quasi sentite dovete morire
no non salta [ __ ] non salta miss
usa con l'aics ok
sì sì ok ragazzi mezz'ora per fare un
salto chi sono si cosi ma se mi toccano
mi ammazzano vero sì potete fottervi
mica vi cucino a pasqua vi cucino giuro
che sta roba eh no però è che palle ma
sentite
no non potresti così mi fanno volare se
mi fa volare la ragazza che cazzo sono
sti così ecco che salta ci avrei
scommesso qualsiasi cosa ma che sai
questo blog creeper che sasha non ha
senso
no salto giusto cosa ormai mi ragazzi si
potrà ghazi credo sia il check point
allora ci prova prova raggiungerlo tra
la [ __ ] lo sapete ma guarda quante
volte ho giocato a chieti mario lo
sapevo e non ho fatto niente sono stare
che me no no lurido no se non riesco
nemmeno arrivare a primo 50 ed è dura ma
parecchio
ok mosso si ok vi stupirete lo farò
senza morire nemmeno una volta
così a caso a caso parkinson gioco
cadono i mulini no no lurido pezzente vi
saltare se ti dico di saltare criminosa
paci che mi ha risucchiato cos'è niente
te la pina e culo si no terminerò tutti
no e adesso puoi pu par melo ok allora
questa ma sarà solo studiata ma non ci
dormono la notte per false cose come non
detto un no allora non mi sono
dimenticato por calabria vi sembra di
essere un deficiente
no ma sì così spuntano dal terreno come
cazzo è possibile ma vengono capito per
cosa forti o pupazzo c'ero quasi poi
morire allora io non ho capito che ho
fatto questo lancia l'este merde come si
sa prefetto nel caso non è possibile che
ha rimediato la sola la calma in attimo
perfetto link e quando arriva un
checkpoint sono contentissimo perfetto
perfetto mamma mia salve mi devo fidare
oppure mimì famiglia e far incazzare gli
deve fare incazzare [ __ ] non so
perché cesto sguardo da deficiente pro
giuro che ti riempio di mazzate in
qualsiasi momento
sono anni che si gira anche a guardarci
associazione fermiamo i suicidi degli
orsacchiotti la cosa non l'ho capita
però vabbè tanto che son cazzi loro mica
miei invece sono anche i cazzi miei
evidentemente no minchia timori se la
famiglia perfetto sarà fermato un attimo
poi s'è buttato giù ha detto vale una
donna è spuntata una rana una una rana a
caso va bene vado avanti a caso sì sì sì
ho vinto ho vinto giuro che adesso esco
e commette un omicidio non sto
scherzando e non idea di che cosa sia ma
io lo prendo
ok e te lo lancia addosso perché sei una
merda secca mi calmi e ho vinto ho vinto
adesso proprio un cazzo può essere
sì dio mio funziona grazie no temo vivo
adesso potevo incazzarmi ok adesso ci
facciamo solo perché sei una deficiente
non ti sai muovere da sola 23 gay non
c'è ma anche nel menu dovete rompere i
[ __ ] mi fa entrare per giocare per
favore no luca sud c'è anche anche nel
menu dovevano tarda sari maroni sono
andava bene c'era neanche un attimo un
attimo di pace no proprio fantastico ok
riuscire ad arrivarci credo si ok
ragazzi dovrei riuscire chi è sto tizio
non lo so ma non la tocco perché so già
che mi deve incazzare vado di qua quando
dico a perfetto perfetto eccolo eccolo
saltato da solo maremma [ __ ] cosa mi
ha lanciato [ __ ] di merda che non sei
altro ok ho fatta adesso sono fatta però
comincia arrivato il cibo insieme si ok
ragazzi ci sono arrivato in tempo record
e sono anche morti in tempo re col
fantastico sentite venite con me perché
eco ed è proposto ranzi fino al midollo
bel traguardo o salto oppure oppure
otterrò di sotto non so io atterro di
sotto perché so già che se salto napione
va bene invece dovevo saltare porca
[ __ ] se una volta c'azzecca assi nelle
cose
[Musica]
ragazzi io io giuro che non è una cosa è
successo un gol che il fungo no il fungo
no sta roba si alza non si alza perfetto
da saltare devo saltare perfetto so cosa
voglia fare ma devo mi sono salvato non
si sa cosa c'è qua dentro c'è un fungo
lo prendo tanto muoiono muoio fantastico
[Musica]
ok se questo ma mi spari in orbita
questo file con tracce non miss fare in
orbita vero ok ok a cala perfetto regalo
lanciato sulle spine non si sa come ha
fatto sì ok stronzo chi è che lancio ste
merde lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo è ok
cosa devo fare adesso ti piace essere
sculacciata e [ __ ] turi da baldas
giuro che ti ammazzo no no va sì sì non
facciamoci domanda è c'è un tirannosauro
in suo livello giacomi prende male lei
ragazza
scusami ma non ti lasciano passare se
vuoi superarmi devi prima battermi
appello litio ma tu sai che stai
sfidando questo non sa con chi è che fa
c'è anche la barra della vita fantastico
devo morire devo scrivere sti cosi si
sofferma faccio felice qui sente lurido
ancora ma è difficilissimo cos'è sta
roba o aristor non mi ha preso non mi ha
preso ragazzi non mi ha preso
luca ragazzi non prezzo di brutto allora
so cosa fa
cani calmi calmi ma come si fa si vabbè
ce la facciamo piovere anche della
dinamite se vuoi datemi una mano come
faccio a fare sta parte non è possibile
non si può fare no no no cazzo no il chi
tentava calcagni il secondo per
chiaramente visto esasperandolo celori
fatta ragazzi non mi chiedete come se sì
l'ho preso l'ho preso
adesso non so dopo il piano un'altra
volta però non so come se vogliamo
lanciare una bomba nucleare da qualche
parte no ti aiuto io se vuoi catmull in
confronto non è un cazzo di niente in
confronto a questo giuro è veramente
assurdo cioè come si fa a fare un
livello così come non l'ho preso madonna
mia se mi ammazza così quante botte
si ok ragazzi forse ho capito se si
faccia già fatta stronzo di merda non ci
si può essere più efficienti di così sì
si può esserlo sì sì sì ragazzi no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no sì
ho vinto ho viste di morire
devi morire male stronzo se sì sì l'ho
già detto sì a ragazzi basta ho tagliato
tipo 45 minuti solo visto livello non ne
posso più dire che abbiamo trovato
un'ottima alternativa arquette mario
fortuna tema che riguarda stesse cose
perché io devo giocare donna vado a
suicidarmi
ragazzi io direi che posso concludere
che i video perché dopo st battaglia
epica mi vissuta anche al cervello
quindi ragazzi servito è piaciuto come
al solito lasciato un momento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come
univideo trattati
solo se lo vorresti di smettere io ci
vediamo prossimo
[Musica]